[Musik]
meine Lieben Zuschauer man weiß nicht so
recht ob es noch gesunde Ehrgeiz ist
oder schon krankhafte Besessenheit
Chinas streben die Supermacht Nummer
eins zu werden man will wirtschaftlich
und militärisch mit den USA enthalten
und an ihnen vorbeiziehen beeindruckend
ist Chinas Aufstieg zwar auf jeden Fall
das Land erlebt in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten ein enormes
Wirtschaftswachstum und mauserte sich
zur Werkbank der Welt aber wir reden
nicht nur über die Wirtschaft china will
nämlich auch geopolitisch den Ton
angeben dabei spielt es keine Rolle ob
wir über die Ukraine den Iran wenn er zu
ihrer Brasilien oder den Südpazifik
sprechen China sagt ständig für
Schlagzeilen die fast immer einen
gemeinsamen Nenner haben PG will seinen
Einfluss so schnell wie möglich auf die
ganze Welt aus denen und dabei verlässt
man sich praktisch immer auf eine Haupt
Zutat nämlich Investitionen
Investitionen und noch mehr
Investitionen das funktioniert auch eine
eine ganze Weile aber jetzt beginnen
sich die Dinge zu ändern und warum nun
weil die chinesische Wirtschaft gerade
eine schwere Zeit durchmacht die
Immobilienblase steht kurz vor dem
Platzen ausländische Unternehmen
Misstrauen dem Land zunehmend das
BIP-Wachstum erreicht auch nicht mehr
die Niveaus für ihre Jahre zwar ging es
Anfang diesen Jahreskurs aufwärts aber
das lag an der Wiederöffnung des Landes
nach dem absolut strengen
corona-lockdowns und erschwerend kommt
hinzu dass viele der Investitionen die
China rund um die Welt getätigt hat sich
jetzt als Fehlschläge erweisen gefährdet
ist auch Chinas Prestige Projekt
schlechthin die neue Seidenstraße das
sogenannte Welt Android project es
handelt sich um eines der ehrgeizigsten
Infrastrukturprojekte der Geschichte und
vielleicht Shisha banks größte Wette
überhaupt
Italien wendet sich von Chinas neuer
Seidenstraße ab mit seinem Ausstieg
versetzt rompikings zum zehnjährigen
Jubiläum der Initiative einen peinlichen
Schlag Italiens geplant er Rückzug
spiegelt auch eine breitere Abkehr von
in der tiefen wirtschaftlichen
Integration wieder die die Beziehungen
zwischen Europa und China seit Jahren
bestimmt für die Chinesen ist das eine
große Demütigung sagte junsunder
Direktor des china-programms am Simpson
Center ganz genau gestartet wurde das
Projekt mit großen Tamtam bereits im
Jahr 2013 also schon vor einem Jahrzehnt
und nach zehn Jahren kann man schon mal
Bilanz ziehen und sehen was daraus
geworden ist oder die Frage lautet also
welche Ergebnisse hat die mit seinem
ehrgeizigsten Projekt bis jetzt erzielt
ist die Zukunft der neuen Seidenstraße
vielleicht gefährdet weil China derzeit
auch wirtschaftlich schwächelt und warum
gibt China im Rahmen solcher
Infrastrukturprojekte Dutzende von
Milliarden Dollar für andere Länder
ausgerechnet sich das wirklich ihr
anschauen sicher anhand der Fragen die
wir aufwerfen dass wir heute über Dinge
reden die nicht so recht so oft
erzählten chinesischen Erfolgsgeschichte
passen es könnte nämlich sein dass sich
die Seidenstraße durchaus als Sackgasse
Endpunkt und deswegen werden wir die
ganze Geschichte heute mal lieber etwas
genauer unter die Lupe nehmen bevor wir
damit loslegen werden wir euch jedoch
noch schnell einen kurzen Blick hinter
die wir so alt Politik Kulissen gewähren
aufgepasst bin
repeat Holzkern
Holzkern Holzkern
ja das stimmt aber es ist nicht das
Wichtigste das wichtigste ist nämlich
ganz egal welche schrägen Typen hier in
der visualpolitik Redaktion unterwegs
sind jeder von uns hat sich in
mindestens eine wunderschöne holzkernuhr
verliebt warum na weil sie wirklich
jedem von uns einen ganz besonderes
Gefühl von Einzigartigkeit und
Natürlichkeit verleihen und aufgepasst
das ist nicht einfach so daher gesagt
die Individualität und Naturnähe von
holzkernuhren ist alles andere als ein
Marketing Gag schon beim Auspacken des
liebevoll gestalteten Päckchen nackt
Mann dass die österreichische Firma
Holzkern ihr ganzes Herz bloß darin
steckt das wirklich jede Facette perfekt
ist und gleichzeitig herrlich natürlich
ist die optimale Verbindung aus
Präzision und natürlicher Eleganz was
will man mehr von einer Uhr sofort
fallen einem natürlich die hochwertigen
Materialien auf aus denen jede Uhr
gefertigt ist ihre Maserung Marmorierung
und das Schülern von Holz Stein und
Perlmutt jedes Stück ist von Natur aus
ein Unikat
die Natur Verbundenheit von Holzkern
zeigt sich jedoch nicht nur in ihren
Produkten sondern auch darin dass ihre
Herstellung Verpackung und die
Lieferketten so nachhaltig wie möglich
gestaltet sind wenn du also wie ich nach
etwas suchst dass Dich täglich daran
erinnert wie verbunden wir mit unserer
Umwelt sind und wie stolz wäre auf ihre
Einzigartigkeit sein sollten dann ist
eine holzkernuhr genau das Richtige für
dich
also lass dir diese Gelegenheit nicht
entgehen und bringe auch deine
Einzigartigkeit mit einer holzkernuhr
zur Geltung natürlich bietet Holzkern
auch das ideale Geschenk für eure lieben
mit einem ebenfalls schönen natürlich
gestalteten Schmuck sollte man so wie
eleganten Damenuhren das ganze ist
selbstverständlich versandkostenfrei und
mit Hilfe des Rabattcodes Politik 15 für
unsere Community den du in der
Videobeschreibung findest erhältst du
alles auch noch und sagte 15% günstiger
in German
Holzkern so und wenn ihr dies erledigt
habt begeben wird uns auf eine Reise
über die neue Seidenstraße der großen
Versprechen wurden sie eingehalten
aufgepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schon länger schaut wisst ihr garantiert
was die neue Seitenstraße ist aber für
alle die es nicht wissen hier eine
kleine Zusammenfassung in den letzten
Jahren hat Peking ein Vermögen in den
Bau aller Arten von Infrastruktur
investiert und plant diese weiterhin zu
tun es geht um Häfen Straßen und Brücken
auf der ganzen Welt da bemühen manche
Medien auch gerne tierische Vergleiche
und zwar von China als einem Kraken der
sich über die ganze Welt ausbreiten will
das erreicht der Mitte solle des Zentrum
der Weltwirtschaft werden es handelt
sich bei der Seitenstraße um einen
ganzen Katalog von Projekten mit zum
Teil gigantischen Ausmaßen Pakistan
genehmigt die Modernisierung seines
Eisenbahnnetzes im Wert von 6,8
Milliarden Dollar das Projekt ist Teil
des milliardenschweren China Pakistan
economic carida Abkommens China 60
Milliarden Dollar für
Infrastrukturprojekte in Pakistan
auszugeben china plant einen 7000 km
langen Hochgeschwindigkeitszug der
Peking und Moskau verbinden soll man hat
durch auch den Eindruck dass auch Größen
waren eine Rolle spielt bei Shisha banks
Bestreben es ist als wolle er die
schiere Größe des alten und mächtigen
chinesischen Reiches wieder aufleben
lassen die Bezeichnung Seidenstraße hat
schließlich auch historische Bezüge denn
eine Straße mit diesen Namen hat es ja
schon mal gegeben zwischen 130 vor
Christus und 1.450 nach Christus war die
Seitenstraße eine der wichtigsten
Handelsrouten der Welt ihren Namen hat
sie von der Seite bekommen die damals
aus China nach Europa importiert wurde
ein damals unbekanntes Blut im Westen
aber es wurden auch alle möglichen
anderen waren gehandelt also Edelsteine
Gold Keramik und so weiter und diese
waren Ströme von und nach China
bestimmten die Geopolitik der damaligen
Zeit die historische Seidenstraße
förderte die Diplomatie sie sorgte für
die Ausbreitung von Ideen der ganzen
Religion und sie begünstigte die
Expansion von imperialien und zwar das
Römischen Reiches des byzantinischen
Reiches des persischen Reiches und der
chinesischen also wenn das keine
geopolitische Bedeutung ist dann weiß
ich auch nicht aber jede große
Geschichte hat auch ein Ende und das kam
auch für die Seidenstraße
zu Beginn des 15 jahrhunderts
boykottierte das Osmanische Reich den
Handel mit dem Westen was zur Schließung
der meisten Handelswege führte die die
historische Seidenstraße bildeten dieser
Umstand zwang die aufstrebenden
europäischen Mächte nach neuen Wegen zu
suchen um Asien zu erreichen und dann
kam ein gewisser Christoph Kolumbus ins
Spiel der auf der Suche nach einer neuen
Handelsroute zwar nicht das begehrte in
den erreichte aber dafür in Amerika
ankam nachdem die Europäer Amerika
entdeckt hatten änderte sich alles
plötzlich kam der Atlantische Seeweg in
Mode und die Seidenstraße verlor ihren
Bedeutung ja und dann beschloss 2013
skijimping sie wie einen Phönix aus der
Asche auferstehen zu lassen der
chinesische Riese kehrte nach
Jahrhunderten der Liter die auf die
globale Bühne zurück aber wie genau
sieht Plan aus und das werden wir jetzt
herausfinden
und der Bescheidenheit zum Gigantismus
die neue Seidenstraße gilt heute quasi
als die Speerspitze der chinesischen
Expansion tja der Ursprung dieser Idee
war jedoch ein ganz anderer und Mut ist
fast schon bescheiden an das Projekt
sollte zunächst den innerasiatischen
Handel fördern schaut euch an 7
September 2013 China schlägt bei einem
Besuch in Zentralasien die
Wiederbelebung der Seitenstraße vor um
die wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen und die
Zusammenarbeit zu stärken und die
Entwicklung der eurasischen Länder zu
erweitern können wir durch die Schaffung
des wirtschaftskorrektors Seidenstraße
ein neues Modell umsetzen der
chinesische Staatschef erwähnte diesen
Plan zum ersten Mal bei
handelsgesprächen mit Kasachstan und
Indonesien so wurde das Projekt mit zwei
Teilen geboren einmal als neue landroute
und als sehr rote die sogenannte
Perlenschnur in jedem Fall beschränkte
sich das Projekt auf sehr spezifische
und feste definierte Initiativen zur
Verfügung des Handels zwischen China und
seine Nachbarn doch das Interesse an
diesem neuen Projekt mit dem alten Namen
war damit bei vielen Ländern geweckt und
Peking fing an das enorme Po sozial
dieses Spiels zu ahnen das Konzept
schien ganz einfach erweiterbar zu sein
Boot Aufträge und Arbeitsplätze für
Chinesen und es würde den Handel stärken
aber das ist noch nicht alles für viele
Länder war dieses Projekt eine
Gelegenheit Geld aus China zu bekommen
sofort bildete sich eine lange Schlange
von Regierungen die bereit waren den
roten Teppich für chinesisches Kapital
auszurollen und in Anbetracht dessen
erhöht die shamping 2017 seinen Einsatz
plötzlich ging es nicht mehr nur um
Asien sondern um die ganze Welt
eröffnete sechs große Korridore und
bezeichnete sie als das Projekt des
Jahrhunderts
seitdem haben sich die Projekte vor
allem in den Bereichen Verkehr Energie
und Telekommunikation vervielfacht aber
auch Krankenhäuser Bildungszentren und
andere Projekte mit sozialen Charakter
sind Teil der Initiative aber sie alle
haben eine Sache gemeinsam in allen
Fällen finanziert peking-projekte und
sein Gegenzug dafür dass die Bauarbeiten
und manchmal auch das Management an
chinesische Unternehmen übertragen
werden außerdem erwartet Peking von den
Empfängerländern dass sie gegenüber der
Außenpolitik Chinas zumindest
aufgeschlossen sind das betrifft zum
Beispiel die Konflikte mit Taiwan oder
den Vereinigten Staaten
wollt ihr ein Beispiel nun ein großes
Thema sind Energie und Verkehr weltweit
hat China bereits 44 Projekte zum Bau
von Kohlekraftwerken finanziert oder
finanziert sie gerade außerdem bauen Sie
Tausende von Kilometern an Straßen und
Eisenbahnlinien und das gibt uns bereits
einige wichtige Hinweise Energie
grundinfrastruktur welche Länder
brauchen denn solche Investitionen genau
das schauen wir uns jetzt an hört gut zu
sag mir mit WEM du dich abgibst und ich
sage dir wer du bist
[Musik]
fast die Hälfte der Länder die sich an
dieser Initiative beteiligen sind Länder
mit niedrigen Einkommen mit anderen
Worten einen großer Teil der
Entwicklungsländer ist mit an Bord zum
Beispiel haben sich 43 Länder in Afrikas
südlich der Sahara den Projekt
angeschlossen und jetzt fragte euch
warum ausgerechnet das so wichtig ist
nur eine weil wir über Länder und vor
allem Regierungen mit relativ geringen
Ressourcen sprechen für die ist oft sehr
schwierig ist Kapital zur Finanzierung
großer Projekte zu bekommen und an
dieser Stelle kommt dann China ins Spiel
mit einer riesigen Kreditkarte und
seinen Investitionen und etwas das wir
als sugar der die Diplomatik kennen wir
haben über diese spezielle Form der
Diplomatie sogar ein eigenes Video
gemacht und ich werde es euch verlinken
und am Strich läuft das Ganze aber so
der böse besten will dir das Geld nicht
geben keine Sorge Papa schieb wird sich
um alles kümmern und was verlangt er im
Gegenzug nun vielleicht deine politische
Loyalität und auch dein Business ihr
glaubt mir nicht
als China im Jahr 2020 das nationale
Sicherheitsgesetz in Hongkong
verabschiedete haben 53 Länder Emo ein
Menschenrechtsrat eine Erklärung zur
Unterstützung Chinas unterzeichnet 25
davon waren afrikanische Länder und die
Länder Nigerias Südafrika und Kenia
unterstützen das Gesetz zwar nicht
schlossen sich der Kritik an Peking aber
auch nicht an normal für alle die es
nicht wissen dass nationale
Sicherheitsgesetz in Hongkong schaffte
dort die Freiheit und Demokratie der
Bürger abschieber damit das Versprechen
ein Land zwei Systeme er schuf1 System
sein System und die Frage ist hatten die
afrikanischen Länder wirklich nötig
dafür zustimmen nun sie befanden sich in
dem was viele als Schuldenfalle
bezeichnen das heißt das Wichtigste dass
China in diesen Ländern fördert ist dass
sie sich bis zum Hals verschulden und
sie dann völlig abhängig von Peking sind
es macht sie praktisch zu Wasser starten
darf man einen Blick auf diese Karte
[Musik]
so sieht die Karte der neuen
Seitenstraße der Zeit aus zu diesem
Projekt gehören bereits Länder die mehr
als ein Drittel der gesamten
Weltwirtschaft ausmachen ja und an
dieser Stelle ist ein wichtiger Hinweis
notwendig in letzter Zeit ist nämlich
die Teilnahme vieler europäischer Länder
an diesem Projekt in erzwergefahr warum
nun weil vielen von ihnen langsam
dämmert zu welch schlechten Bedingungen
Sie hier mit Peking Geschäfte machen am
Anfang dieses Videos hatten wir bereits
das Beispiel Italien erwähnenswert ist
aber auch Litauen denn Litauen wird von
China sanktioniert weil es eine
diplomatische Vertretung Teil Wahnsinn
in seiner Hauptstadt errichtet hat tja
da wird der sugar der die ganz schnell
ungemütlich
[Musik]
das Perfide daran ist lange sah alles
sehr gut aus mit der seinen Straße china
hat zugestimmt gemeinsam mit
Investitionen mit über 140 Ländern zu
tätigen das sind 140 Länder die jetzt
eine viel engere Beziehung zu picking
haben und viel stärker von ihm abhängig
sind aber folgendes ist vielleicht der
wichtigste und abschlussreichste Teil
der ganzen Geschichte es gibt nämlich
ein Länderranking der politischen und
bürgerlichen Freiheiten erstellt von der
Nichtregierungsorganisation Freedom
House diese NGO hat das Ziel liberale
Demokratien zu fördern und im Ranking
von Freedom House sind die Länder mit
den niedrigsten demokratiewerten
zufällig auch jene die am stärksten mit
China verbündet sind etwa zwei Drittel
aller Projektpartner China sind Länder
die in Demokratie Ranking sehr weit
unten stehen mit anderen Worten peking
will einen Block bilden der Ausländern
besteht die ein gemeinsames Muster haben
starten die relativ arm sind ihren
Einwohnern nur wenig Freiheiten bieten
und keinen oder nur ein sehr schwaches
demokratisches System haben ja und da
überrascht ist auch nicht dass die
meisten Diktaturen dieser Welt beim
Seitenstraßen Abenteuer mit an Bord sind
um euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben
es gibt 57 Länder auf der Welt die als
autoritär und unfrei gelten also im
Grunde genommen ziemlich autoritäre
Diktaturen sind das sind Staaten in den
Dinge wie Videos oder Pressefreiheit
nicht geduldet werden und von diesen 57
Ländern beteiligen sich ganze 52
aktivieren Pinks mega Projekt das Kalkül
und die Logik dahinter ist eigentlich
glasklar je weniger demokratisch ein
Land ist desto leichter ist es eben
seine bedingungslose Loyalität zu
gewinnen es reicht ja die herrschenden
Eliten zu überzeugen und sie mit Geld
und presst die Projekten zu versorgen
auf diese Weise gewinnt man deren
Loyalität und das ist dann der Schlüssel
zur sugar Lady Diplomatie wie gesagt das
Konzept der sugar der die Diplomatie ist
wirklich hoch interessant ihr solltet
euch deswegen unser Video dazu unbedingt
noch mal ansehen wir haben das ganze
dort am Beispiel Sri Lanka durch
dekliniert ein Land das heute am Abgrund
steht und ich weiß das klingt jetzt
alles unglaublich böse und Maria
willistisch aber es funktioniert und
zwar ganz egal ob wir im Westen das nun
gut finden oder nicht allerdings haben
wir über eine Sache noch nicht
gesprochen denn Loyalität und politische
Abhängigkeit ist das eine aber
funktioniert das ganze auch
wirtschaftlich und sind da wirklich
starke und dauerhafte politische
Allianzen entstanden so dass China
endlich seine Träume von der
Weltherrschaft verwirklichen kann nun
mittlerweile müsste man ja ein paar
handfeste Ergebnisse sehen können oder
und deswegen schauen wir uns diese jetzt
mal genau an
China aus Geld nimmt man gerne
einschließlich China selbst ist mehr als
die Hälfte der Länder der Welt auf die
ein oder andere Weise am Projekt
Seidenstraße beteiligt fast alle
Entwicklungsländer unterhalten jetzt
viel engere Beziehungen zu picking tja
das Problem ist aber das nicht alle
diese Länder ihre Finanzen in Ordnung
haben
und die geplante Schuldenfalle droht nun
zu einer Art Bumerang für China zu
werden die Politik des Wachstums um
jeden Preis funktioniert langsam nicht
mehr sowohl innerhalb als auch außerhalb
Chinas ich habe es bereits erwähnt die
chinesische Wirtschaft befindet sich in
einer nicht gerade rosigen Phase
Wirtschaft steckt in der Falle Chinas
fette Jahre sind vorbei die
Konjunkturprogramme in China könnten die
Verzerrungen noch verstärken
Stimulierungsmaßnahmen im
Infrastrukturbereich könnten das
Wachstum zunächst zwar erhöhen aber zu
einem weiteren Anstieg von
Ungleichgewichten und einer
Fehlallokation von Kapital und damit
mittelfristig zu einem schwächeren
Wachstum führen auch die Schulden in
China wurden immer mehr zum Probleme ab
2016 begann die chinesischen Behörden
zwar alles Mögliche zu tun um die
Überschuldung abzubauen insbesondere bei
den staatlichen Unternehmen das hat
jedoch nicht geklappt und 2020 wurde es
noch schlimmer im November 2020
erschütterte eine Reihe von Insolvenzen
staatlicher Unternehmen in chinesischen
Markt für Unternehmensanleihen sich das
Finanzsystem im Februar 2021 zog die
peoples Bank of China die interbanken
Liquidität ab was zu einem deutlichen
Anstieg der Zinssätze führte mit anderen
Worten diese Bank verleiht kein Geld
mehr an andere Banken man vertraute sich
einfach nicht mehr untereinander so wo
die regionalen und kommunalen
Regierungen als auch China staatliche
Unternehmen sind heute vollkommen
verschuldet bis zum Hals stecken sie in
Forderungen allerdings ist diese
Verschuldung des Staates in den
offiziellen Statistiken nicht sichtbar
sie verbirgt sich in den Bilanzen der
öffentlichen Unternehmen dort schiebt
man die Schulden einfach hin
wir haben mal ein ausführliches Video zu
all diesen finanzproblementen China
gemacht und ich was euch verlinken das
Problem ist nun vor allem in einer Welt
mit steigenden Zinsen dass der
Schuldendienst das Wachstum abwirkt man
hat einfach kein billiges Geld mehr um
es zu investieren und damit zu wachsen
diese Schulden Probleme stecken hinter
den Nachrichten wonach sich das
chinesische Wirtschaftswachstum in den
letzten Jahren immer mehr verlangsamt
hat und das ist noch nicht alles seit
2018 sind auch die Zahlungsausfälle bei
chinesischen Unternehmensanleihen
exponentiell gestiegen
das Hauptproblem bei einer schnell
wachsenden Schuldenlast von Unternehmen
besteht darin dass erhebliche Mengen an
neuen Krediten verwendet werden müssen
um ältere Schulden zu bedienen so dass
jeder neue Kredit nicht mehr die gleiche
Wirtschaftstätigkeit wie in der
Vergangenheit erzeugt dieses Problem ist
so groß dass die Zinsen für die in China
ausgegebenen Schulden bereits jetzt das
Wirtschaftswachstum des Landes
übersteigen und wenn die Wirtschaft
langsamer wächst wird die Schuldenlast
umso erdrücken darf was wiederum das
Wachstum bremst ein Teufelskreis die
chinesische Katze hat sich ganz einfach
in den eigenen Schwanz gebissen aber
okay was in aller Welt hat das und mit
der Seitenstraße zu tun nun halten wir
fest das Problem ist dass China in den
letzten 10 Jahren sein
Wirtschaftswachstum und dadurch aufrecht
erhielt indem es sich immer tiefer
verschuldet hat das heißt es wurden
riesige Projekte durchgeführt die einen
investitionsblase im Land erzeugt haben
und warum nun riesige Projekte müssen
auch riesigen Nutzen bringen doch viele
dieser Straßen Gebäude und Schienen und
auch Flughäfen haben längst nicht den
erwarteten Nutzen gebracht die Dinge
stehen teilweise vollkommen Sinn und
Zweck frei in der Landschaft herum
und das hat dazu geführt dass die totale
Faktorproduktivität der chinesischen
Volkswirtschaft trotz riesiger
Investitionen immer weiter
zurückgegangen ist sie liegt heute weit
und uneinholbar hinter den USA zurück
und falls ihr wissen wollt wieso diese
totale Faktorproduktivität geopolitisch
unglaublich bedeuten ist dazu haben wir
ein Video gemacht und ich werde es euch
verlinken kurz gesagt mit diesen nur
schlecht genutzten riesenprojekten macht
man keinen großen Gewinn alle die Easy
investiert haben bleiben heute auf den
Schulden ihre Investitionen sitzen und
diese Misere ist ein Massenphänomen in
China ja und wisst ihr was auf diese
Weise lief es nicht nur in China selbst
auch in vielen Ländern die sich dem
seitenstraßenprojekt angeschlossen haben
wir wirtschaftete man auf die selber Art
aber schauen wir uns das doch mal etwas
genauer an passt jetzt sehr gut auf
Grund prüfe der mit Geld sich bindet
mit der neuen Seidenstraße bzw den Plan
one Road one Welt wie ihr offiziell
genannt wird begann das große Geld zu
fließen China schickte eine riesige Flut
von Dollars das Problem dabei wenn es
darum geht diese Schulden zurückzuzahlen
Tröpfe das Geld nur Sperlich
Ski droht das kreditviasko zehn Jahre
später hat die Wirklichkeit Peking
eingeholt denn Kredite vergibt man am
besten nicht nach politischen sondern
nach wirtschaftlichen Kriterien weil die
nicht so war droht China zunehmend ein
hoher Kreditausfall mit anderen Worten
viele der Länder die chinesische
Investitionen erhalten haben sind jetzt
nicht mehr in der Lage die vereinbarten
Schulden Zahlungen zu leisten die
chinesische Regierung ist gezwungen
ihnen aus der Patsche zu helfen oder das
Problem ist dass das alles viel zu teuer
wird laut einer aktuellen Studie von
Forschern von eight data der Weltbank
der Harvard Kennedys Kieler Institut für
Wirtschaft musste China allein zwischen
2019 und 2021 fast 100 Milliarden Dollar
Grundschulden seiner Partnerländer
begleichen insgesamt geht es bereits um
200 Milliarden Dollar an Hilfen für
Länder wie Angola Pakistan Venezuela Sri
Lanka und den Sudan all diese Kredite
waren für den Aufbau der Infrastruktur
gedacht aber in Ländern die so korrupt
und arm sind versickert das Geld
wahnsinnig schnell es geht drauf für
Bestechung und die Bauprojekte erreichen
ihre witzige Kostenüberschreitungen
viele dieser Infrastrukturprojekte
wurden nicht genutzt um etwas zu bauen
das wirklich funktioniert sie wurden
eher missbraucht damit irgendjemand in
den betroffenen Ländern sich die Taschen
vollstopft so mancher große oder kleine
Diktator ist mit dem Geld von Papa Ski
noch reicher und mächtiger geworden und
wir reden hier nicht über ein oder zwei
Projekte die schief gelaufen sind schaut
euch mal an bei 35 % des Infrastruktur
Projekt der Seidenstraße Initiative gab
es ernsthafte Probleme bei der Umsetzung
darunter korruptionskandale
Arbeitsrechtsverletzungen Umweltrisiken
und öffentliche Proteste also bedeutet
das nun dass die neue Seidenstraße er
einen großer Fehlschlag ist und irgendwo
im Nirgendwo endet nun ist sie
tatsächlich schlecht aus holprig ist der
Weg allemal und China wird da wohl oder
übel durchmessen es ist wie ein
Reifeprozess was genau bedeutet
gut zu
der Silberstreif am Horizont
zum ersten Mal seit Beginn des 21
jahrhunderts steht China vor einem
starken Wirtschaftsabschwung die
investitionsblase die es im In- und
Ausland geschaffen hat könnte bald
platzen aber die vorhin genannte Studie
behauptet auch folgendes Chinas
derzeitige Krise könnte eine Art
Reifeprozess darstellen den das Land bei
seinem Aufstieg eben durchmachen muss
die Studie besagt wirklich folgendes wir
sehen historische Parallelen zu der Zeit
als die USA ihren Aufstieg als globale
Finanzmarkt begannen und Ländern mit
großen Verbindlichkeiten gegenüber
US-Banken und Exporteuren Rettungsgelder
zur Verfügung stellten im Laufe der Zeit
wurden diese ad hoc Aktivitäten der USA
zu einem bewährten System des globalen
Krisenmanagements
mit anderen Worten china könnte lernen
wie es mit Problemen bei seinen
Investitionen in diesen Ländern umgeht
und die notwendigen Mechanismen
entwickeln um sie zu bewältigen wie
damals bei den USA könnte das ein sehr
wertvolles Instrument werden um die
wirtschaftlichen und finanziellen
Beziehungen zu all diesen Staaten am
Ende zu stärken natürlich gibt es große
Unterschiede nach den Zweiten Weltkrieg
boomte die Wirtschaft in den USA das
können wir von China nicht behaupten
ganz so schweigen davon dass das Regime
von verschiedenen Ping eine strenge und
intransparente Diktatur ist und viele
der an der Seitenstraße beteiligten
Staaten ebenfalls außerdem ist das
Problem mit China auch kein besonders
kompetenter Diktator ist denn ein
wirklich Wege Diktator hätte wissen
müssen dass er seinen Pappenheimer nicht
trauen kann wahrscheinlich haben alle an
diesem Spiel Beteiligten großen wie
kleinen Diktatoren ihr Geld was sie aus
dem seidenprojekt Ziehen in die USA oder
zumindest in den Westen geschafft und
tun es noch immer tja und China bezahlt
die ganze Party es sieht also nicht gut
aus für das seitenstraßenprojekt und
erst recht nicht für die Menschen in den
darin beteiligten Ländern die sich
vielleicht sowas wie Wohlstand erhofft
hatten aber an dieser Stelle
interessiert uns erstmal was ihr denkt
glaubt ihr China wird sein
seitenstraßenproblem noch irgendwie
lösen können oder könnte Chinas Aufstieg
hier sein Ende finden wie immer sind wir
auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt es bitte ein Like fallen
und diskutiert ist auch mit ihnen
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch mit uns dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]